one more of Karin Jean-Pierre I'm just
bludgeoning these people today uh her
response on why Americans are not happy
with the Biden economy despite the fact
she keeps telling everyone it's bottom
up and middle out and a whole bunch of
other meaningless dribble the president
is claiming the state of our economy is
strong but 41 of Americans think they
are worse off financially than they were
when President Biden took office the
most negative response to that question
in the history of ABC polling now if the
economy is strong why don't more
Americans feel that way
because it's been a very hard couple of
years
it's been a hard couple of years was
there something that happened
involving the government that might have
made this difficult on people like a
thing that the government chose to do
that maybe like locked people in their
house and forced people to inject
themselves with weird stuff and not let
kids go to school and basically broke
the brains of like 350 million was
there's I'm gonna have to we'll Google
that lost my pen we'll Google that uh
what she doesn't want you to know of
course is that inflation under this
Administration Has Gone Bananas these
are stats know what they give you they
give you platitudes I'm going to give
you stats here is the inflation here
we're going to break it down over the
series of a couple months January of 20.
it was at 2.5 percent January 21 1.5
July of 21 here's where it started to
move 5.4 percent January of 22 so that's
a year ago now it jumped to 7.5 percent
this past summer July of 22 9.1 and
November 6.5 so yes it has ticked down
lightly as you're looking there but much
like that information we showed you the
graph we showed you about gas prices it
is significantly higher than when Joe
Biden came into office this is why I
show you things with numbers and charts
something that is completely the reverse
of what these clowns on MSNBC do when
they do their live laundering they bring
on Administration people to just say
nonsensical things and then they just
repeat them
[Music]
foreign